the president Trump meets with
Republican senators on Capitol Hill
today to discuss tax reform Tennessee
senator bob Corker will be there the
Foreign Relations Committee Chairman
calls a visit just a photo op and corker
reportedly described the Senate's budget
process as a hoax because it does not
address real spending it's not the first
time the Republican has spoken out he
told the New York Times this month the
president's threats to North Korea were
reckless and could put the us on the
path to World War three and when the
president criticized corkers decision
not to run for re-election
the senator tweeted it's a shame the
White House has become an adult day care
center senator corker is with us from
Capitol Hill good morning good morning
good to be with you
well then laid it all out there and now
the president's coming to Capitol Hill
to talk with you guys about tax reform
today I know you said you've said you
think the president should step aside
from this process is he being a
distraction are the comments that he's
making the tweets making it harder to
get tax reform done well we've got one
thing that's not talked about in this
process enough is we have four trillion
dollars worth of loopholes credits we've
got things that have to be closed this
is what the American people want they
want tax reform that makes it simple for
them to fill out their tax returns but
if you keep taking those things off the
table in advance then you really don't
have a path to get to this four trillion
dollar number which is important to do
what's been laid out so I would let the
tax writing committees do their work I
think both the House and Senate has done
a lot of preliminary work and stay out
of taking things off the table and
really negotiating against the process
before it even begins I understand what
you're saying because there's a
suggestion by Republicans on Capitol
Hill that it's time to cap the
contributions for 401ks by wealthy
Americans and the president said
yesterday in a tweet there'll be no
change that seems to be hurting the
process you're saying well again there's
numbers of other things that
see state and local deductions and
people moving away from that so look
it's not religion to me which ones we
close or don't close at least not at
this point but we need to leave
everything on the table to be successful
and when you begin on the front end
taking those things off it makes it more
difficult but I hope we're going to be
successful I hope we can create economic
growth but I hope we do so with not in
any way increasing the deficit which is
the greatest threat to America right now
senator the former President George Bush
George W Bush Bush 43 Senate former
senator and President Barack Obama have
all spoken about the country and the
mood of the country without naming the
president they seem to be doing what you
also have spoken about the fitness of
the president what are your concerns
about this president well look I this is
I've gotten another president in a very
unique way over the course of the last
year and I guess like all Americans I
would have hope that he would rise to
the occasion and bring out the best in
our nation charlie hopefully what
presidents do is to try to bring the
country together to unify around common
goals and and not to debase our country
if you will and that has not happened
and I'm beginning to believe that it's
not going to happen and I think that's
what President Bush President Obama many
others have been concerned about as it
appears to be the governing model of
this White House to purposely divide I
mean that's what happened after the
Virginia incident it's to consolidate
base not to bring people together and to
bring out the better angels of those
people in our country this is a great
nation and without us doing that it
really not only affects us in future
generations but it affects the world and
so I hope I don't really hold out a lot
of hope but I hope that somehow a little
bit different course of action can be
taken we keep hearing privately senator
corker that many people feel the way you
do so what's being done about it on
Capitol Hill well look you know we're
we're separate and equal branches
there's tremendous power that resides in
the White House one of the things we're
going to be doing beginning a week from
this coming Monday night we're going to
beginning we're going to begin to walk
through a series of discussions about
the authorization for the use of
military force what powers the president
has talked about some of the
international alignments that we have
that are very important to our country
making the American people even more
aware of some of the destructive things
that are happening so you know that's
one thing we can do can also be a check
legislatively but look an individual in
that particular position has tremendous
power to set the tone for our country
and unfortunately it's being set in a
way that I think is not bringing out the
best in the citizens that that we all
treasure here in our country so you know
I'm doing the best I can without you
know tried to do so in a statement like
manner but I think this is shared by
many Americans yes do you feel free to
speak out the way you do because you've
announced that you're not running you
know I spoke out before announced I
wasn't running I think everybody's aware
of that it's been building for some time
I made very strong comments after the
incident in Virginia when again it felt
it felt like the president was just
trying to consolidate a base of people
that and do so in a way that again I
thought was very inappropriate even
before that I've made comments so it's
been building for some time and look I
came up here on a two term mission I
told people in Tennessee that I couldn't
imagine serving more than two terms so I
have felt independence really the entire
time I've been in the Senate Thank You
senators thank you thank you thank you
all thank you